[INAUDIBLE] done this work
in the last few years,
we made reinforcement
learning more mature,
closer to the real world and
[INAUDIBLE] applications.
He has worked on many topics
related to that on deep
reinforcement learning,
on motor planning,
on planning of trajectories
as rewards, and also on
the fundamental algorithms
which [INAUDIBLE] talked about.
And he's going to speak today
on all of these algorithms,
on the policy gradient methods,
so thanks, John for [INAUDIBLE].
>> Thanks for the very nice
introduction, Sebastian.
So I wish I could be out there
in Cambridge with you and
participate in
the summer school, but
unfortunately, I'm not
very good with jet lag.
So I decided to stay home for
this one.
So this tutorial is going to be,
this is gonna be a policy
gradient tutorial which is
closely related to the tutorial
that Pieter Abbeel and
I gave at NIPS this year but
with some modifications.
And it's actually gonna
be fairly basic and
just introduce the basics
of policy gradients,
evolution strategies,
natural policy gradient.
But actually, I think the basics
go a really long way for
these algorithms, so I hope
it's beneficial for all of you.
So before I get into
the details of some of
these algorithms that
I'm gonna talk about,
I wanna just put them into
context a little bit with
the other algorithms from
deep reinforcement learning.
So deep reinforcement learning
is just reinforcement learning
where you're using neural
networks as your function
approximators.
And one interesting thing is
that in reinforcement learning,
there's several different
choices of what to approximate.
This contrasts with, say,
supervised learning,
where you just wanna
approximate your conditional
probability distribution or
something like that.
So in reinforcement learning,
there's several
reasonable choices.
You can try to approximate
a policy which is your function
that chooses the next action.
You could try to approximate
a value function,
which is a function that tells
you how good a certain state is,
or a certain
state-action pair is.
Or you could try to learn
the dynamics model,
which predicts
the next state and
the reward, which you would then
plug into a planning algorithm.
So here in this talk, I'm gonna
focus on learning policies.
But I would say that there's
sort of a taxonomy of
different methods that sort
of live in this space.
So on the one hand, you can
directly optimize policies.
And one way to do that is with
derivative free optimization or
also known as
evolutionary algorithms,
where you just try to optimize
over the parameter vector
without using anything
about the actual
trajectories generated from
that parameter vector.
So you're just treating the
whole environment as a black box
where you put in a parameter
vector and you get a return.
Then there are these policy
grading methods which actually
take advantage of the temporal
structure of the problem and
try to figure out which
are the good actions and
which are the bad actions.
Let's make the good
actions more probable.
Let's adjust our actions so
that they're better.
So that's sort of what we've got
on the policy optimization side.
And dynamic programming is
another class of algorithms that
are based on learning value
functions and in the, so there's
a set of classic algorithms
that will exactly solve an MDP
where you have access to all
of the information about
the transition probabilities and
the reward function.
So there's these algorithms
that you might have learned
about in the elementary course
of policy iteration and
value iteration which
will exactly solve for
the optimal policy and
the value function for an MDP.
And it's possible to come up
with approximate versions of
these algorithms.
So that's another class of
methods there, and Q learning is
sort of an approximate version
of, or DQ learning is sort of
an approximate version
of value iteration.
But we're going to focus,
here in this talk,
I'm gonna focus on the policy
optimization methods.
Well first,
what's the difference between
empirically and
also sort of conceptually?
Well, one big
advantage of the policy
optimization method is you're
optimizing the thing you
care about which is the expected
return of the policy.
In contrast,
the dynamic programming
methods are more indirect.
They try to exploit
the problem structure
to learn a value function using
a self-consistency property that
the value function should have.
Specifically, that the value
function now should be
consistent with the value
function of the next time step.
So they can be So there's
a slight mismatch between what's
in your loss function which is
the [INAUDIBLE]
consistency edition and
what you actually care about
which is the expected return.
But empirically what happens is
the policy optimization methods
are a bit more versatile,
meaning they tend to
work in more situations.
Whereas the dynamic programming
methods are more sample
efficient when they do work.
This is just a very rough
assessment of the empirical
results and the jury is
still out on which methods
are going to work the best
in the long run, but
this is just the current
state of things.
And also, the policy
optimization methods are more
compatible with richer
function approximators,
such as recurring
neural networks,
and also architectures that
add auxiliary objectives,
such as making predictions,
in addition to control.
So that's the advantage of
the policy optimization methods,
whereas dynamic programming
methods are more compatible with
off policy learning.
And in turn, that makes them
more compatible with exploration
because to do exploration, you
often block once to collect data
from a policy that other than
the one that's your current
best guess at
the optimal policy.
Okay, so that's just an overview
of where policy optimization
methods sit relevant
to the other methods.
But now, so now I'm gonna get
more into the details and
set up what the problem
is more precisely.
So we're gonna be concerned
with parametrized policies,
and what that means is you
have a family of policies
that's indexed with
some parameter vector,
which in this case is just
a vector of real numbers.
And this could either be a
deterministic policy where that
action is a deterministic
function of the state and
the parameter vector or you
could have a stochastic policy
where the action is
a conditional probability
distribution that depends on the
state and the parameter vector.
And this is totally analogous
to classification of regression
where the state is your input
and the action is your output.
And you can use the exact same
kind of function approximators
that you would use in
classification or regression.
For example, if your
reinforcement learning problem
has a discrete action space,
you can take a network
architecture that would have
been used for classification,
where your network outputs
affect your probabilities.
Whereas if you have
a continuous action space,
you can use a network that
you would have use for
regression where the network can
be interpreted as outputting
a mean and a diagonal
covariance matrix for Gaussian.
Also for the purposes of
this talk, we're going to be
concerned with the episodic
reinforcement learning setting.
There are actually several
different ways you can set
up the optimization problem.
When it comes down
to the algorithms,
it actually doesn't
matter that much,
since the algorithms
look basically the same.
But we're gonna be
mostly concerned with
what's called the episodic
setting where we have an agent
whose experience is broken up
into a series of episodes.
Each of which has a finite
number of time stamps.
So in each episode you sample
an initial stage from sub
distribution Mu.
And the agent acts until
it reaches a certain
terminal state.
At which point the episode ends.
Just to give you a few examples
of what an episode might look
like, let's say you
have a taxi robot and
the episode ends when it
reaches its destination.
So then termination is good and
we want the episode to
terminate as fast as possible.
You might also have a situation
where the episode has a fixed
length, and you're just trying
to accumulate as much reward as
possible during that
fixed amount of time.
So that would be like a waiter
robot finishing where
the episode ends when it
finishes this shift, or
you could have another
kind of the rear,
you want the episode to
be as long as possible.
Like you have
a walking robot and
you wanted to us be able to
stand up as long as possible or
stay out for as long as
possible before falling over.
So the goal in this setting
is to maximize the expected
reward per episode.
So we're gonna use capital
R to denote the return,
which is to be distinguished
from the reward.
Cuz the reward corresponds to
a single time step will return
corresponds to a whole episode.
So reward will be lowercase
r and return is capital R.
And we're concerned with
maximizing the expected return,
which is the sum of reward
in the whole episode.
So there are various ways of
optimizing this expected return.
And first,
I'm gonna talk about what's sort
of conceptually the simplest way
to do it which is with
Derivative Free Optimization.
And the idea here is you have
your parameter vector which
defines your policy.
And we treat everything
as if it's a black box.
So actually what's happening
inside the black box is
there's a series of time steps.
At each time step you're
sampling an action and
then generating next
state in reward.
But we're gonna
ignore all that and
just say we put the parameter
into that black box,
get a return which
is stochastic.
And use that information to try
to adjust our parameter vector.
So first time we gonna talk just
introduce an algorithm called
the cross entropy method,
which is simple to
understand intuitively.
And that'll give you
an intuition for what's kind of
going on in these derivative
free optimization methods, and
then I'll talk a little bit
more about how to justify it.
The first, just introduce
the algorithm are the main state
is here meaning
our current estimated about
the parameter vector.
The actual parameters is
stored in two vectors,
we have a vector mean
deviation parameter.
So we're, that means we have
a Gaussian with diagonal
co-variants over parameters and
what we're gonna do is
improve this distribution
over parameters.
So each iteration,
what we do is,
first we collect n samples, then
random parameters by sampling
from this Gaussian distribution.
Then for each parameter vector,
we perform one episode with it,
that means we just
run our policy for
one episode until
the episode terminates.
And that gives just a return,
that's the type.
I should just say return,
capital R.
Then after we've done
these n episodes,
we take the top p% where p is
a parameter of this algorithm.
We take the top p%,
like the top 20%, Now we
fit a new Gaussian distribution
to the elite set and
update mu and sigma.
So fitting it, that just means
usually we do maximum likelihood
on that elite set.
I mean if you are familiar
with evolutionary algorithms,
this will be a kind of familiar
structure where you have
a certain population which
is defined by a Gaussian
distribution.
And then you pick the members
of the population that have
highest fitness and you fit
a new distribution to those
highly fit members of
the population, and
then you repeat
the process again.
So it sort of makes
sense that you're just
moving your distribution towards
the good parts of parameter
space over time.
And so you're doing this for
awhile and then at the very end,
after you've done all
of your iterations,
you return the final mean
parameter which is your best
estimate for
the optimal parameter.
So this simple algorithm is
called the Cross Entropy Method
for certain rhetorical reasons
which you said it's related to.
It's actually a method it was
derived for something else, for
integral estimation but actually
I won't go into the details for
that.
But the funny thing is
sometimes this algorithm works
embarrassingly well and
in particular So
the game of Tetris has, for a
long time, been a benchmark task
in reinforcement learning or in
approximate dynamic programming,
which is sort of means the same
thing as reinforcement learning.
And so this table is
taken from the paper,
Learning Tetris using the noisy
cross entropy method, and
it shows that there are several
previous papers that
used reinforcement learning
techniques to play Tetris and
they got certain scores that
are in the low thousands.
So it's not the best
performance.
The best performance is attained
by this hands coded policy or
by genetic algorithms and
both of which there's
a lot of hands engineering
in both of these cases.
And the paper that this table's
taken from showed that if you
just use the cross entropy
method, you get a really high
score which is competitive with
the best performance obtained by
these kind of
handscrafted methods.
And you get much better
results than any
of the reinforcement
learning methods.
So in particular methods that
are based on policy iteration
and policy gradients, so when
I say reinforcement learning
methods, I mean methods that
exploit the fact that you're
trying to solve an entropy and
try to take advantage
of the temporal
structure of the problem.
So I think the reason why
this happens is because
the cross entropy method
is optimizing, well,
mostly optimizing
the right thing,
which is the performance of
the parameter vector, over many
thousands of time steps that
it takes in an episode.
Whereas, the reinforcement
learning methods have to
make some approximations.
So even though they're
exploiting the structure of
the problem, they end up
optimizing the wrong thing.
In particular, they have
to introduce what's called
a discount factor where
you sort of ignore long
term dependencies and I think
that's probably what kills them.
But you don't need to worry
about a discount factor with
the cross entropy method.
I'm gonna talk about
the discount factor shortly.
So, anyway, a few years ago,
there was a paper showing that
by being really careful about
how you proximate your value
function, you actually
can get good results on
Tetris using the [INAUDIBLE].
But I still think it's
sort of a win for
cross entropy because of how
simple the algorithm is and
how it works pretty well
without that much tuning.
So I didn't really justify
the cross entropy method,
though it sort of makes
sense intuitively.
But now I'm going to talk about
a very closely related approach
which can be mathematically
derived pretty
straightforwardly, which
is to do stochastic
gradient ascent on the
parameters of your distribution.
And shortly I'll show how cross
entropy method is closely
related to this shortly.
So the idea here is in cross
entropy method, we had this
Gaussian distribution and
we're categorically moving this
Gaussian distribution to give
better and better returns.
So can we just do Stochastic
gradient descent or
Stochastic gradient ascent on
these distribution parameters?
So that's what we're
gonna do here.
So let's say that we
use this distribution
piece of mu over our
policy parameters.
Well, mu could be
the mean of a Gaussian or
it could be the mean of
the standard deviation.
Let's pretend for now we're just
optimizing over the mean and
we're gonna fix
standard deviation.
And the same method can be used
to adjust the standard deviation
but usually that's not
very useful anyway.
So let's just say we're
optimizing over the mean of
a Gaussian distribution.
So the return depends on the
policy parameter and some noise.
So let's just say we've defined
everything so that the return is
its deterministic function
of the parameter vector,
theta, and some noise zeta.
So now our optimization problem
can be written Like follow us,
we're maximizing a view of
the expectation of our return
where the parameter theta sample
according this distribution.
So, well this is a little bit
non straightforward because
our return is unknown and
it's possibly nondifferentiable.
So we don't know this function R
and it's probably not a nice and
smooth function of
the parameter vector theta.
So I mean,
especially let's say we have
the discrete action space.
Then clearly,
R isn't gonna be a deterministic
function of our
policy parameter.
So it's kind of not obvious
that we can even do this or
that we can even
differentiate this.
But as it turns out we can.
And it's a very basic and
important
technique called the Score
Function Gradient Estimator.
Also known as the Likelihood
Ratio Gradient Estimator.
The way it looks is the gradient
of this expectation
equals the expectation of grad
log probability times return.
So what we've done
here is we've just,
I mean the idea of the gradient
estimator is you're
trying to estimate the gradient
of this expectation and
we wanna write that
as an expectation of
something which we
can then compute.
We can get a Monte Carlo
estimate also.
So here we can get our
Monte Carlo estimate by
just collecting a bunch of
samples and then taking for
each sample we take gridlock
probability times return.
And we take the empirical
average of those.
I'll derive this in a sec, but
before I derive that, let's just
look at the relationship between
this score function gradient
estimator and what we were doing
in the cross-entropy method.
Here Score function
gradient estimator,
we've got grad log
probability times return.
Whereas in the cross-entropy
method we have an objective
that we optimize each iteration.
I actually didn't write this in
the algorithm, the sudo code.
But, the way we fit the
distribution to our data points
is we do max and likelihood or
we maximize the log probability
of our elite set under
the paramaterized distribution.
So what that means is, so what
``we have here is if we look at
all of our samples, not just the
elite set, what we have is log
probability of the sample times
some function of the return.
And in this case, what we did in
the cross-entropy method is we
just took the indicator that
returned R was above thresholds.
So we could see the zero one.
And so
you can see that if we got rid
of this thresholding function f,
then the objective we're now
maximizing in each batch in each
iteration of cross-entrophy is
deemed as the objective we've
differentiated with the scored
function gradient estimator.
So you can see that they're
gonna do similar updates, but
maybe the cross- entropy
method we'll do,
we'll be able to take a bigger
step each iteration because you
don't have to just take
a single gradient step.
Actually another illuminating
connection is between the score
function gradient estimator and
between doing
finite differences.
So it turns out that the score
function grading estimator is
very similar to doing towards
another kind of intuitive
algorithm that involves
taking a random direction and
doing a directional derivative
in that direction, and
then doing a gradient step using
that direction derivative.
So I'll show you that this
core function gradient
estimator comes out to be almost
the same as a certain kind
of direction [INAUDIBLE].
So see that let's just compute
explicitly what happens with our
score function gradient
estimator in the Gaussian case
where we're optimizing over
the mean of the Gaussian.
So here's our log
probability and
then when we take the gradient
of the log probability.
So, it's just parameter minus
mean over standard deviation
squared and then so
here's our estimator,
rewardr times the parameter
minus the mean.
Okay, so it doesn't look so
illuminating yet.
But now let's say we do
antithetic sampling.
So if you have a symmetric
distribution such as a Gaussian,
you can compute
your expectation.
You can get the same
expectation by collecting
two samples at a time,
where you collect a random
sample from your
distribution and
then the [INAUDIBLE] of that
sample, or the mirror image
of that sample around
the center of distribution.
So this is just a general
kind of Monte Carlo
estimation technique called
antithetic sampling.
So here, what we do, each step
we take a pair of samples,
mean plus noise times
standard deviation,
and mean minus noise
times standard deviation.
Here, z is from normal zero one,
meaning
mean zero standard deviation,
I mean, varies as the identity.
And sigma is, this is our
vector of standard deviations.
So this is
an element-wise product.
Or you can just consider
the scalar case for
now if you don't wanna
worry about vectors.
So anyway, what we're gonna do
here is write down the score
function gradient estimator,
but where you used
antithetic sampling, so
you got two samples at a time.
So writing [INAUDIBLE]
average of our two samples,
we have return at one sample
minus return at the other sample
times our z, which is our noise,
which is just normal zero one.
So what we have here is,
we have z is effectively
just a random direction.
Because we just sampled
a random vector.
And then we look at
the return measured
at correct mean plus z and
mean minus z,
scaled appropriately.
So, this is just our
finite difference.
And we're dividing by the size
of the probation sigma.
So here, this is just our
directional derivative.
And then we're multiplying it
by the random direction that
the derivative is taking it.
So this is the kind of intuitive
algorithm, sometimes called
simultaneous perturbation
stochastic approximation.
It's not exactly, I don't know,
I don't wanna get into
specifics of that.
But this is a kind of
intuitive algorithm.
And you can see that it's
exactly what you get by doing
the square function gradient
estimator with antithetic
sampling.
And yeah, so if you use
different noise samples to do
both function evaluations,
then you could potentially
have a lot of variance.
Because it could be that
most of the difference
between these returns is
coming from the noise,
and it's not coming from
the difference in parameter.
So you end up having an error
term that goes like 1/ sigma.
So if you have a very small
sigma, and you use two different
noise samples, then you
get a pretty bad estimate.
But if it's the same noise
sample, so it's zeta equals zeta
prime here, then you get
a much better estimate.
Because what happens is, well,
under almost all conditions,
these two terms are gonna
be positively correlated.
So meaning when you take
an expectation over zeta,
these terms are gonna be
very positively correlated.
So if we take the difference of
them, we're gonna cancel out
some of the noise
that comes from zeta.
So anyway,
we get much lower variance if
we're able to freeze the noise.
And so if we have
access to a simulator,
for example, then we can use
the same random seed and
evaluate two different parameter
vectors for that random seed.
Of course, in the real world,
we can't do that.
Okay, so basically,
that's sort of three
different views
on During pre-optimization.
And we have these kinda similar
algorithms that we get.
I'll just quickly show how
you derive the score function
gradient estimator, in case
you haven't seen this before.
So this is the estimator that
I wrote on the previous slide.
So you can just derive it
by writing the expectation
as an integral and then you
just swap the integral and
the gradient and
you can do that whenever
the probability
distribution is continuous.
Actually it doesn't even
have to be differential,
it just has to be almost
everywhere differential.
So, as long as it's almost
everywhere differential you can
derivative and
then you get this.
Then what you have to do is,
so by the chain rule,
when you take grad
log probability,
that's equal to grad probability
divided by probability.
So what we've done here
going from equation two to
equation three here is
we've just multiplied and
divided by
the probability density.
Okay, so, then the reason
we did that is so
we can turn the integral
back into an expectation.
Because we need to have
some probability measure
multiplying the integrands.
So we turn it back into an
expectation and now we got this
expectation of grad log
probability times return.
So, that's, okay,
that's my overview on
the derivative pre-optimization.
There are several different
versions that which are similar.
Actually the algorithm where
you do random direction
finite differences and
you use stochastic gradient and
that is usually called
evolution strategies and
this is from the 70s.
Then it is also related
to this SPSA algorithm.
So cross entropy method has
become pretty popular for
applications where you have
a fairly small number of
parameters.
And there's actually another
version of it which is even more
popular called covariance matrix
adaptation, where instead of
using a diagonal covariance, you
use a full covariance matrix.
But there are also some other
tricks which help get a better
estimate of this full
matrix because otherwise,
you wouldn't be able to estimate
it from a single patch.
So CMA, covariance matrix
adaptation is a way of
[INAUDIBLE] updating
your covariance matrix.
And this is very effective in
a lot of problems where you have
this fairly small
number of parameters.
And these are also pretty
closely related to some
algorithms that have been more
focused on the robotics or
reinforcement learning setting,
reward rated regression and
power algorithms.
So, CMA has actually
been very popular and
successful for optimizing
locomotion controllers for
simulated robots and
also a little bit for
real robots, but
I won't go into that.
So, for example,
there's this long running
challenge of playing soccer,
robot soccer,
which is done in simulation and
in the real world.
But the leading teams in
the simulation league,
what they do is they optimize
a bunch of controllers for
walking and for
getting up off the ground.
First, they parameterize
this controller, so
they have some kind of 20
parameter thing, which is
a trajectory which is gonna be
followed with PID where you have
to tune a bunch of targets and
gains for PID controllers.
So they parameterize this thing,
some kind of trajectory, and
then use CMA to optimize
over the parameters.
And they do this for walking and
getting up, and so on.
So and then they use CMA
to optimize this parameter.
And it's also used for
optimizing locomotion
controllers, more in the.
Projects of computer graphics
where you're trying to get
physically realistic
walking controllers.
So, it's been quite successful
in this kind of application.
There's a recent paper showing
that Evolution Strategies
performs pretty well on
the Atari benchmark,
which has been used for
deep reinforcement learning.
So the previously Q learning and
policy gradient methods have
been shown to do well on Atari.
And Salimans at all showed that
if you just used the evolution
strategy using the same kind
of network which was used for
policy gradients it actually
is competitive performance.
They might be a little bit
worse, in terms of sample
complexity, but actually, well,
it's much easier to paralyze.
So it might have its advantages,
in some cases.
And it's also not as,
us sensitive to certain,
it doesn't require as many sort
of approximations as policy
gradient methods where
you have to worry about
like skip frame skip you
have to repeat actions for
multiple frames otherwise
It doesn't learn very well.
Or and policy grading methods
you also have to worry about,
you have to introduce
discount factors.
So the nice thing about
evolution strategies is,
or the black box
optimization approach is,
you don't have to worry about
the time horizon as much.
So you don't have to worry about
what's called credit assignment,
where you're trying to figure
out which actions were
responsible for the awards,
since you're just directly
optimizing in parameter space.
Okay, so that's it for
evolution strategies.
I would stop for questions, but
I'm not sure if It's going to
work very well, because I can't
see everyone, and I'm not sure
if their microphones, I'm not
sure if I'd be able to hear you.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, then why don't I just,
I'll just open it up, if anyone
has any questions before we
go on to the next section.
[LAUGH] All right,
I think we are ready to go to
the next section.
[LAUGH] Okay,
to the next section, great.
So, Policy Gradient Methods.
Okay, so the problem we're
trying to solve again,
is to optimize these
effected reward,
expected return of
a parameter policy.
And what we're going
to do here for
policy gradient method is we're
gonna have a policy parameter
theta which is fixed at any
given point in the algorithm.
And we have to do it overtime,
but instead of keeping
track of the distribution
over policy parameters we're
gonna have a single policy
parameter at any given time.
And we're gonna estimate
the gradient of this expectation
with respect to
the policy parameter.
So, one way to think
about this is,
now our noise is in action space
instead of in parameter space.
So the intuition of what we're
going to do is we collected
a bunch of trajectories to use
using our parameterized policy.
And, well, there's three
different ways to thinking of it
which are all correct.
And correspond tells you
different kinds of methods.
One is we try to make the good
trajectories more probable.
So, if we do that,
we don't have to worry about
the individual actions.
We just have a whole
trajectory and
we're trying to make the good
ones more probable and
the bad ones less probable.
Okay, then what we can try to
do to get better policy grade
estimates, is figure out
which actions were good and
which ones were bad.
And then we try to make the good
actions more probable and
the bad actions less probable.
And then there's a third
class of methods which
actually try to.
These only really make sense if
you have a continuous action
space, and
these methods will try to
push your actions towards
slightly better actions.
So you try to estimate.
These require some kind of value
function which will tell you
how good a given action is, and
it'll push that toward
a better action.
So I don't think I'm gonna
have time to get into those,
but that's another
interesting class of methods.
So now I'll get into how you
actually do that mathematically.
And the way it works, we're
gonna use the same kind of score
function grading estimator that
we used in the derivative-free
optimization setting.
Except now our random variable,
instead of being
a faulty parameter.
Is the whole trajectory.
Remember how I said that the
noise now is an action space or
trajectory space rather
than parameter space.
So now our random variable
is the whole trajectory.
If we just go through
the motions to derive the score
function estimator, we get
a perfectly estimator here,
which says that the creating
of the expected return is
just the expectation of gradual
probability trajectory,
times return trajectory,
which is just recall part,
return is just
summary of rewards.
So, that's not so
useful by itself because we've
got this probability of
the whole trajectory and,
by the way, it's worth talking,
at this point,
about which variables or
which quantities
are assumed to be known.
And which ones are not known,
when we're trying to
run our algorithm.
So for example,
I mean you have to assume.
I've just written down
this optimization problem.
But I haven't said
anything about
whether we know what the MDP
parameters are and so on.
So do we know what the
transition probabilities are?
And do we know what
the reward functioning is?
Or are these things quantities
that we have to estimate?
We're going to be interested
here in the setting that,
we don't know what the
transition probabilities are,
and we don't know what
the reward function is.
But we have to learn anyway.
So, our learning
algorithm has to either
learn these qualities or somehow
just learn the policy without
having access to
those quantities.
So actually, it's worth
appreciating that well, this
is kinda nontrivial, but even if
you have this problem with all
sorts of unknown quantities that
we can still optimize the policy
for it, even though we don't
know what the dynamics model is.
Which exist inside
of this expectation
because it determines what our
trajectories are gonna be.
So it's just worth noting
that this is quite different
from other regime wherein
with another kinds of machine
learning, most other machine
learning problems not
a bandwith problems.
So bandwith problems you
assume you have this unknown
distribution of returns
from the different arms.
Something like supervised
learning usually you
have a finding set
of training data.
But given your training data,
you have analytic access to
the full objective you're
trying to maximize.
So you can compute gradients
of your objective.
And even second derivatives,
and so on.
Like here, we don't have
the analytic access to this
expectation that we're
trying to optimize.
It has quantities in
it that we don't know.
So, when we write out the
probability of the trajectory,
we can just use the chain rule
probabilities to write it as
a product.
The probability of the initial
state, that's not,
times the probability,
the products overtime,
the probability of action times
probability of x stated or more.
Okay so, we know that
probability, we have access to
this part of probability
action given state and
parameter vector because
the policy is part of our agent.
This is what we're learning.
So we can think derivatives and
so forth of this.
But we don't know what the
transition probabilities are.
We don't know what
the initial distribution is.
So that's gonna cause
trouble if we wanted to
somehow analytically
evaluate this expectation.
But we could of course do
Monte Carlo estimates of it.
And that's what we have to do.
Okay, so when we take
the log of this probability
it turns the product into a sum.
And then we take the gradient
of this log probability.
And now all of the terms that
don't depend on theta drop out
of this expression.
So that's nice because all
the terms that has disappeared.
And then we're left with, and
you're then just plugging that
back into our estimator formula.
We get the following.
We have.
Expectation over
trajectories of return times
the gradient of
the probabilities.
So this formula, let's just look
at this formula for a second.
This formula means that you,
so you can get a Monte Carlo
estimate of the expected
return by taking a bunch of
trajectories, generating
a bunch of trajectories.
And then for each one, we take
the return of that trajectory
and then we take the grad
log probability of
the actions along
those trajectories and
we multiply return times
grad log probability.
And that gives us our empirical
estimate policy gradient.
And the interpretation is,
sometimes we're gonna get
a high return, sometimes
we're gonna get a low return.
We want to maximize
the log probability
of the samples that
have a high return.
So we're gonna move our
distribution over to put
more probability mass
on those samples or
probability density
on those samples.
Okay, so that's the most kind of
gradient estimator we can get.
So what we can do
now is try to derive
more variance
grading estimators.
And that's the major that
has the same mean but,
it's great to have
more variance.
So it's gonna be
a better estimator and
it's gonna require fewer
samples to get a good estimate.
The way we do that is we
can run through the exact
same argument to get
the grading estimator for
a single reward term.
In the previous slide,
we were trying to get the grad
expectation of
the summer rewards.
Now we're just going to get grad
expectation of a single reward.
So grad expectation of
this r sub t prime.
So just doing the motions,
we get that it's equal to r
sub t prime times the sum of
grad log probability of
the preceding actions.
Because the past actions
aren't going to affect
this prefered a null.
So we don't need to worry
about the subsequent actions.
So, then we wanna get the grad
expectation of the summer
rewards, capital R.
So we just sum this
formula over T prime.
Sorry, I said sum it over T,
I meant sum it over T prime.
So okay, that leaves us, so
you just do the bookkeeping
there and what we get is the sum
of reward sub T prime times
the sum of grad log probability
of proceeding actions.
Or you can rearrange it to
the grad log probability
times the sum of the rewards
after that action,
so sum of following rewards.
So the interpretation of this
formula is if you get a high
rewards, that means that your
preceding actions were good,
so you should make
them more probable.
This formula says that if,
for a given action,
if the sum of following
rewards were high,
then we should increase
the probability of that action.
And these formulas,
it's just a trivial
rearrangement of the sum.
It's just bookkeeping to you
switch between these two
formulas.
So this is a better estimate
of the policy gradient which
respects causality.
Now we can reduce the variance.
So the name of the game is
variance reduction because
the policy gradient is
what we care about.
And now we just wanna get
estimated as well as possible,
as fast as possible, which
means reducing the variance
as much as possible
of our estimator.
One really good variance
reduction technique is to
introduce what's
called a baseline.
So the intuition behind
the baseline is,
in our previous formula,
let's look at the last formula.
We've got grad log probability
of the actions times the sum
of following rewards.
So if we get and make
an empirical estimate of this,
we're going to adjust
the probability of every
single action we've performed.
In our sample trajectories
to try to increase it.
Let me say that again.
So we collect a bunch of
trajectories then we plug
those trajectories
into this formula.
And so that means we would take
gridlock probability with each
action times the sum
of our awards.
And we take that gradient
at descent step.
So that means we're increasing
the probability of, sorry,
let's say all our our
rewards are positive, but
let's just suppose they're
positive in a certain problem.
That then,
where our gradient descent
step is gonna try to increase
the probability of every
single action we just took.
But that seems like a bad idea,
because some of the actions were
good, and some of them were bad.
In fact, half of them were good,
and half of them were bad.
So the idea behind the baseline
is, we want to only increase
the probability of an action if
it was better than expected.
So, only about half of
the actions were better than
expected.
So we should only increase the
probability of the good ones.
So now instead of just
multiplying gradient by
probability by this following
rewards, we [INAUDIBLE]
minus some baseline where
the baseline was the estimated
what will turn out to be
a great choice for the baseline
is the expected return
before taking that action.
So okay, so one nice fact
is that for any choice of
baseline the gradient
estimator we get is unbiased.
I won't show the derivation
in this slide show,
but it's very easy to
derive by just looking at.
Well, it turns out if you
take the expectation of
the gradlog probability where
we're sampling from pi,
this expectation comes out to 0.
And you can see that, yeah,
that's sort of a well
known fact in.
So any choice of baseline
that we plug in here is
gonna not introduce bias.
And it turns out that a near
optimal choice to plug in here
is just the expected return.
Conditioned on
the state s sub t.
And intuitively that's because
we only want to increase
the probability of action t
if the returns that you got
here were better than expected.
So that means we should plug
in the expected return here.
So actually it turns out this
isn't the optimal choice that
minimizes variance.
The optimal choice actually
involves some kind of weighted
estimate of the return.
As it turns out, it's near
optimal and it's as good,
for all practical purposes,
it's the best you're gonna do.
You can also, another way to
derive this is to just write out
the formula for the variants.
So the variants of x,
some random variable x, is just
expectation of x squared minus
the expectation of x squared.
So if you write that out, and
you make some approximations
about things being independent
then you'll find that you just
want to minimize the expectation
of this term squared,
of some of the words
might based like squared.
So that means you should
just take this base line to
be the main of this quantity,
for
the best possible less
to at this quantity.
So that's a very useful and
powerful variance
reduction technique.
And that'll get you a lot
of mileage in practice.
The other technique that
gets you a lot of mileage is
to introduce discounts.
How am I doing on time,
by the way?
Does this session
actually ends now?
>> Ten minutes.
>> Okay, okay good.
I'll finish up in the next
ten minutes, okay.
So another method is gonna give
you a lot of mileage is to
introduce discount factor.
So, since so far I haven't
added any discounted factors,
but and
I've as I said before working.
I've been talking about
the episodic setting where you
just care about the sum of
rewards over a whole episode.
Sometimes, if you read
reinforcement learning books,
you'll see a different kind of
problem setting where Where
you're actually optimizing
a discounted sum of rewards.
And I think this is
the reasonable thing to do.
But often the time horizon
you care about is very long.
So for example,
you might care about, well,
in that Tetris benchmark I
was talking about earlier,
the game might take
a million time steps.
So that means if you want
a discount factor that actually
includes all those [INAUDIBLE]
steps and counts all of them,
it would need to be 0.99999,
right?
So anyway, what the discount
factor is is it's a,
So it's downgrade to
the effect of future rewards.
Sorry, I didn't explain.
In reinforcement learning
textbooks what you
sometimes see is you care
about the sum of reward times
this r sub t times
gamma to the t.
So the problem with that is
that, is that that's basically
going to ignore all rewards
that are far into the future.
So I think that this
problem setting doesn't
usually make sense.
And I think it makes
more sense to think about
the discount factor as
a variance reduction parameter.
Or at least in the policy
grading context,
what it does is it gives
you a [INAUDIBLE].
So the way we're gonna introduce
the discount factor here
[INAUDIBLE] going to modify
our previous formula for
the policy gradient by
introducing the discount factor.
So recall that our
previous formula,
what we have is sum of
rewards minus baseline.
So here, we're just gonna
modify it to be sum of rewards
multiplied by this discount
factor, minus baseline.
So this discount factor,
you can see that the discount
factor measures the difference
in time between this reward and
the action you're looking at.
So it's based on
the assumption that
the action only affects rewards
in the near future, but
after that, the effect of
this action is washed out.
And it's not going to,
anything we can measure whether
this action was good or bad.
We have the next by looking
at some short horizon
after the action.
But the system kind of forgets
the effect of that
action after a while.
And okay, so if we use this
discount factor then if we wanna
then by the same arguments
I was providing before,
we want the baseline to be
the expected discount at
some of the rewards so that we
can maximally reduce variants.
And the way you can also
think about this discount
factor as it's doing
credit assignment by
assuming that the action
deserves no credit for
rewards that are far
into the future.
So if your discount
factor is 0.99,
then 100 time steps
later you're sort of
downgrading everything by
a factor of 1/e and so on.
So that's the idea of using
this discount factor, and
now it's just worth looking at
the formulas we've shown so far.
And one way to interpret them
is as multiplying gradlock
probability times an estimate
of the advantage function.
So I haven't defined
the advantage function yet
but you can think of
the advantage function.
What I mean by this is that
the advantage estimate is
just telling you whether
the action was good or bad.
So we're just multiplying
gradlock probability times some
scalar which estimated whether
the action was good or bad.
And in this case,
we're just taking that scalar
to be the discounted sum of
following rewards minus
the baseline, okay.
So putting everything together
that we shown so far, what we
get is this so-called Vanilla
Policy Grading Algorithm.
And so
the way this works is iterate,
first collect the set of
trajectories by executing
the current policy
Then at each timestep,
we compute the discounted
return, which is the sum of
future awards down-weighted
by discount factors.
And we compute
the advantage estimate,
which is defined as this
return minus the baseline.
Then, we refit
the baseline by doing,
this is just a nonlinear
regression problem.
So we can set up a least
squares optimization,
where we fit the baseline
to the returns.
And then we update the policy by
computing a policy gradient
estimate which is the sum
of the terms of the form
gridlock probability times.
And actually there's
a slightly modified version of
this which is sort of a more
modern version which is
compatible with very
efficient implementations is
what we call the Advantage
Actor-Critic algorithm.
So there's this paper,
Asynchronous Methods For
Deep Reinforcement Learning,
which introduced what's called
the Asynchronous Advantage
Actor-Critic algorithm A3C.
So that's the asynchronous part
doesn't really matter here.
It's just sort of for
performance reasons.
What I'm presenting here
is what could be called
the Advantage Actor-Critic which
is sort of the vanilla policy
gradient algorithm with some
modifications that make it
more compatible with
efficient implementation.
So the way it works is
now instead of collecting
full trajectories,
you collect a certain
fixed number of timesteps for
each update.
So you have your agents and
it asks for
T timesteps such
as 20 timesteps.
And then for each timestep
along that trajectory segment,
you compute the return and where
you cap it off with the estimate
of the value function at
the end of the trajectory and
you compute the advantage
function also at each timestep.
And so we're going to use
the return as the target for
the value function in
your regression problem.
And value function is
synonymous with baseline,
if you're not that
familiar with it.
So v here can also be thought
of as the baseline v that
we were using in
the previous slide.
So here we're gonna use R as
the target value function,
and A as the estimated
advantage function.
And we just set up this loss
function which has our policy
gradient loss, which is grad log
probability times advantage,
and then also a value
function regression error.
And this can be plugged into
a stochastic grading algorithm
such as Adam.
But this is exactly the same
thing we were doing before but
it was, like something is just
a version that uses a fixed
number of timesteps at once
instead of using collect and
fold trajectories.
Okay, and even though this
is very simple and basic,
when you run it for a really
large number of timesteps,
you can get pretty
impressive results,
such as navigating a 3D maze.
Just use learning a policy
which is a convolutional neural
network which navigates a 3D
maze using only pixels as input.
So this was from deep line,
about last year from Vlad and
the collaborators, and
I have a video actually of that.
So actually I'm out of time now.
So I just want to show a couple
of videos just to sort of
show what you can do
with these methods.
So I'll show the video from
the [INAUDIBLE] player
which is navigating a 3D
maze using pixels as input,
using exactly this algorithm.
And I'll also show a video of a,
I didn't get to this
part of the presentation,
but there's also some
methods you can do to
get more information from
the data you collect.
So you can do a better update
where instead of just doing
a gradient update, you set up
a trust region problem and
you solve that.
So you set up a little
constraint optimization problem
and you do an update on that,
and
you end up getting better
sample efficiency.
And also,
sort of more reliability.
So I'm not gonna-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> What?
>> Yeah, so
I'll show the first video, and
then, so that's labelled 1-A3C.
And then, the last thing that I
also wanna show the video that's
E-PPO, which is sort of,
or actually show 2-CRPO,
which is learning to
run in simulation,
which is based on this trust
region kind of algorithm,
which I didn't have
time to talk about.
So Ian,
please show the first video.
Okay, good.
And then, once that's done,
start the 2-TRPO video.
I can't see what you're showing,
so [LAUGH] just tell
me when it's dark.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, cool.
Okay, so this is a video
that collaborators and
I were working on.
Learning locomotion controllers
from scratch where you
just have this 3D [INAUDIBLE]
simulator getting [INAUDIBLE].
The input is just the joint
angles and joint velocities and
so forth, and
the output is the joint works.
And so it's a pretty low level
representation of everything.
And it starts off just falling
over instantly, but eventually,
it starts falling over a little
bit more slowly, and so on.
And so finally,
it's actually running and
it can actually run indefinitely
long after learning is complete.
And then,
there's nothing in that
algorithm specific to running.
So you can also use it on
a four-legged creature and
You can also use it on learning
how to get up off the ground.
So we defined, I don't know if
we've gotten up to that part
yet, but we defined
the reward function which is
something like distance of your
head from some target height.
And then, it'll learn how to do
some kind of ballistic motion
with its arms and
get up off the ground.
And so people have previously
done learned locomotor controls.
So we weren't the first
people to do that, but
previous attempts have usually
used much more hands coded
representations where you
specify, for example,
that you're trying to place your
feet left, right, left, right.
And your network is just
determining where to put your
foot, for example.
Whereas we just had
a feet forward network
mapping from observations
to actions directly.
So yeah, so this was a video
produced by my collaborator
recently where it's just using
So basically you've got
this guy running around and
being hit in the head by bricks.
And he still manages to
get up off the ground.
And he's running
towards the red ball.
So you see these red
balls randomly appearing.
So here your reward function
is not just to run forward.
But it's to run
towards the ball.
And the balls randomly appear.
So I mean, when you see this I
think it becomes more possible
you could actually get
football or something if
you really put these
skills together.
So i'm pretty excited about
what we can do with that.
That's using something called,
we call it proximal
policy optimization.
It's basically, it's like trust
region policy optimization,
but you use a soft constrain
instead of a hard constrain,
and actually,
I'm gonna put out a paper on
that in the next week or so.
So you can check out So it'll
be on the archive in a few days.
So yeah, I wish I could tell
you about more of this stuff,
but we're out of time,
and it's late over there.
So hope you all
enjoy your evening.
>> [APPLAUSE]